uh very good morning to you
just a day after a third covid19 vaccine
was introduced and
politicians are this morning trying to
boost public confidence in the programme
it follows a decision by doctors to
offer everyone under 30 an alternative
to the astrazeneca jab
after evidence the drug was linked to
blood clots
now also this morning new official
figures show the infection rate in
england
fell by about 60 from february to march
but it appears this decline is now
leveling off
we'll talk to the health secretary in
just a few minutes but first this report
from sadia chowdhury
[Music]
marianne mcgowan has cerebral palsy and
so she got her first dose of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
in february
with a second dose due in a matter of
days marianne's mother says the issue of
blood clots
has created uncertainty am i really
anxious i'm just not about sure there's
no really mentioned anything
regards to the under 30s that get
disabilities
and they're in a wheelchair and they're
not able-bodied
marianne is among those under 30
awaiting a second astrazeneca dose
knowing that doubt over its risk means
guidance has changed
in favor of an alternative jab for
younger age groups
the risk of clotting is extremely rare
and only occurs in a very small number
of people
but in communities where there is
already some vaccine hesitancy
is it going to make matters worse
in luton they may now need some
convincing
you're supposed to take vaccines to feel
safer so if it's going to cause you
stuff like blood
clots like that's a bit worrying
but in london anything to get back to
normal
i'm an actor i haven't worked in a
theater for over a year and so
for me as many people just can get
vaccinated as possible it means that my
industry can open up again
the british medical association says
benefits still outweigh the very low
risks associated with the astrazeneca
jab
and that the vaccination program must
continue
the risk of blood clots has occurred in
people with having had
the first dose but not a risk after the
second dose so the advice
according to the regulator according to
the evidence
is that you should proceed to having
your second dose
and be properly protected from what is a
deadly virus
today one of the country's largest
studies into covid19 infections
is published it says vaccines are
already having a significant impact on
hospitalizations and deaths
and it comes as the health secretary
reiterates his plea to the nation
to accept the offer of a vaccine when it
comes
sadia chowdhury sky news
well let's talk to the health secretary
matt hancock joins us now good to see
you this morning
look how concerned are you that this is
going to cause
some sort of drop off in vaccine uptake
well there's no need for that we have
seen this incredible level of
uptake of the vaccine in this country
and what we've learned in the last 24
hours is
the the rollout of the vaccine is
working
we've seen that the safety system is
working because
the regulators can spot even this
extremely rare event
four in a million and take necessary
action to
ensure that the rollout is as safe as it
possibly can be
and we're seeing that the vaccine is
working
it's breaking the link between cases
and deaths the number of people dying
from covid
halved again just in the last nine days
since i last spoke to you
and is down 98 from the peak
so we we can have confidence people can
take confidence that we have a
system that we are extremely careful on
the safety front
but that the rollout is progressing at
pace so when when you get the call
get the jab do you think the mhra the
regulator was
was was right to raise this concern in
the way it has i mean
ian duncan smith has said you know this
is a gift to the anti-vaxxers who are
just going to turn around and say
we told you so
well thankfully in this country we've
seen this amazing level of take up far
hard night would have
possibly expected you know if you'd
asked me three months ago
uh if we get to this level of take-up i
i
couldn't have believed it frankly it's
over 90
in all over 60s groups and in the
clinically extremely vulnerable over 99
of people have been coming forward for
their second job 99.4 that's an
incredible rate
and i think people can be reassured that
we have
the high class safety system
run by our world-class regulator if you
like
and the mhra we and then we're totally
transparent
with all of the side effects no matter
how
extremely rare they are like these ones
and it means that independent people
like i just heard
you had the head of the british medical
association
he's totally independent of government
but as a doctor
as a gp he can look at the data that we
published and he's come to his own
conclusion and his conclusion is that
you should get the jab because this is
our way out of the pandemic
but but it does raise questions about
that the amount of concern
it does cause and of course that's
that's inevitable i mean when you
pause distributing a certain vaccine to
the under 30s that is going to cause
concern
and yet as you said yeah the risk here
seems to be
four people out of every million while
the contraceptive pill
carries a risk of five people developing
blood clots in every
ten thousand so if if people find it
acceptable
to take the contraceptive pill they're
not worrying about that potential side
effect particularly
is it right to have raised to the public
awareness this very very small concern
about the astrazeneca vaccine
well it's absolutely right that we are
completely transparent and that we have
this
highly sensitive safety system that can
spot even these extremely rare events
and i it is important though that we
we are clear about the policy so i just
want to
set it out because it's slightly
different to what you said in the
question there
um people these the all three vaccines
that are
in use in the uk are safe and they're
safe at all ages
but there is a preference for the under
30s and so we'll
for under 30s if they want to have the
pfizer or moderna jab
instead then they can um but
the not only the british regulator but
even the european regulator and indeed
the world health authority
yesterday said that the oxford
astrazeneca jab
is safe and we know that it's highly
highly effective
and there's one other important point
here which is that
of course the regulator has taken into
account
the the risk the extremely rare risk
to individuals but the benefits don't
only go to an individual for getting the
jab but to everybody
because getting the jab reduces your
chance of getting covered very
substantially
but it also reduces your chance of
passing it on to your loved ones
and we should all think about that and
take that into account and i think that
that
the combination of those two things is
one of the reasons why the uptake has
been
so high here in the uk as i say over
90 percent for all the all the
uh the over 50s uh and in fact
over 95 percent for people who are in
their
uh their their 70s and 80s and above oh
okay so how is this going to work then
for the
under 30s as it currently stands when
they start to enter the program which
for the vast majority of them is a
little while off
yet you're saying it's so it's not being
absolutely pause but you're just
offering an alternative
i mean logistically how does that work
well there are 10.16 million
people aged 18 to 29 in the uk
1.6 million of them have already had
their first jab
anybody who's had the jab should
continue with the second jab because
there's no evidence of this effect after
a second jab and we have
enough more than enough a moderna
vaccine to cover
all of the remaining eight and a half
million
uh people aged between 18 and 29
if necessary now as you say it's some
time before we'll get on to
to that cohort cohort 12 as it's called
you know the next
step once we've made sure we've got that
offer out to everybody
in the current groups groups one to nine
the over 50s
then we'll move on to the people in
their 40s people like me
and then people in their 30s and after
that we'll come to
people aged 19 to 29 and we'll make sure
that they have the
option of having the fisa or the modern
jab
if they want to and we have large
numbers of
jabs coming on stream we have 40 million
pfizer jabs in
uh in production we have 17 million
modern jabs that are coming through so
as you can see
you know thankfully because we've been
working on this for for over a year now
we've got more than enough jabs and we
are on track to hit the
target that we've set that we will
ensure every adult in the uk is offered
the jab by the end of july
in terms of having enough jabs i mean
that obviously gives us a great deal of
confidence here but what are we doing
about
sending uh some of these vaccines
elsewhere there are reports in the
sydney morning herald today that we've
already sent about 300
000 uh astrozenica vaccines
to australia but it's been sort of kept
under wraps a little bit
have we done that
well we've made sure that we can get the
jabs
that we need here and that's why we have
the fastest
rollout and obviously we work with the
the companies
the three companies astrazeneca pfizer
and
moderna the three companies that we're
now using their jabs
here in the uk um and um
and then we've got more coming on track
and we talk to these companies
all the time about the best
route to making sure that we can get
these uh
these vaccines and obviously we're
engaged with our european partners as
well
yeah but to your to the best of your
knowledge how have we sent
300 000 to australia
uh well we've produced the vast majority
um of the jabs that we're using the
astrazeneca jobs
here in the uk in terms of what the
companies do that's a
that you know these these companies are
manufacturing for all around the world
and we source from
everywhere in the world so you know
there's a what matters
what i'm in control of what matters for
us as the uk government is making sure
that we get the supplies that we have
contracted
from the companies and it's something
we've discussed many times with respect
to
uh yeah so it serves with our so the the
the british government hasn't sent any
abroad
no the british government has a contract
with well with um with
with seven companies now uh but of
course including astrazeneca
uh for the delivery by astrazeneca to
the uk for us to deploy through the nhs
and that's the bit that i'm responsible
for
um well in terms of those you talk about
seven companies where
are we with the getting the novavax
vaccine
on board and also the the johnson
johnson which i think is the single jab
vaccine which could prove to be very
useful
where are we in that process
well we've got three other really
promising vaccines
and then there's the cure vac which is
about having a vaccine that
we can adapt quickly for new variants if
there's a problem with new variants
you know the three others that aren't
yet approved by the regulator but are
proceeding really well
are the novovax vaccine
which is going to be made here on t
side the valniva vaccine which is going
to be made in
is being made in in livingston in
scotland
you saw the news no doubt earlier this
week that that has passed its phase
two trials so it moves on to the phase
three trials so that's
proceeding that's going well and then
there's the the yanson vaccine that is
the single shot vaccine
and we have that coming on stream in the
summer so all three of those are yet to
be approved formally by the regulator
but they are in in the case of two of
them they're being used elsewhere in the
world
we are in uh we're in good shape on the
supply
of future vaccines and
obviously we had the great news that we
started the roll out of the modern
vaccine yesterday
in camarvin in in wales so
it's you know the vaccine program is
proceeding well
the speed of the vaccine program is not
affected by the decisions yesterday
you can see and be reassured by the fact
that we're
taking an abundance of caution and we're
making sure that we're rolling this out
in the safest way possible
and i hope that people can take from the
approach that we're taking
obviously listening to the best science
in the world
that people can have confidence in
getting the jab
because we know that it's safe and we
know that it's effective
and getting this pandemic under control
here in this country which is
obviously what we all want to see
because that is the road back to normal
and look just before we let you go can i
just ask you about the situation in
northern ireland i mean
whatever has sparked this and there is
some concern that it may be linked to
the whole
northern ireland protocol and
frustration over the brexit situation
but but how concerned are you how
concerned is government
about what is happening there and what
now can westminster do to assist
well of course we're concerned and the
uh the the root out of this is dialogue
and i'd encourage all sides to engage in
that dialogue
it is of course policing in northern
ireland is of course a devolved matter
and the the reasons for this
uh violence are complex i've spoken to
the northern ireland secretary
and he and the prime minister are
obviously working very closely
on this from the uk government point of
view
we would like to see all sides engaged
in that dialogue
and this be resolved as a devolved
matter by the people of northern ireland
minister always a pleasure thanks very
much indeed for your time this morning
thanks for having me political
correspondent rob powell
is here and it's all about maintaining
the confidence here in the jab and i
guess
we do have to look at these figures of
what is it for in a million people who
could be affected by this it's
a very small figure yeah it's
vanishingly small i think what the
health secretary was doing there was
trying to re-emphasize what we heard
yesterday about the relative
minor change actually that has taken
place saying that this isn't a case that
the jab is unsafe for any age group this
isn't even actually the case
that the roll out of the astrazeneca jab
is being stopped in an age group it's
just that there's
a preference being introduced for the
lower age groups and he was sounding
reassuring and confident about the
numbers of supplies of pfizer and
moderna
that we have of course at the moment
actually the majority of vaccination
that's happening will be second shots
that are going into the arms of older
people many of whom will be having the
astrazeneca jab and need that second
dose
to get the long-term protection and on
that matt hancock said that there was no
evidence
of these blood clots happening after the
second shot although we heard in the
press conference yesterday that actually
that there isn't the data to tell
whether that's happening yet because
of the relatively few number of people
that have had the second shot
but he did say that uptake was very very
good the figure he put on it was 99.4
percent of people coming forward
um for uh the second jab so
sounding confident but not really
wanting to engage in that question of
if the risk is so small and if this
change in advice is so
minor was it worth doing it in the first
place
given the impact it could have more
broadly on confidence in the vaccine
okay rob thank you well so to come
this morning we're going to talk to the
chief inspector of offset at half past
seven as they begin an investigation
into allegations of sexual harassment in
schools in england
and at five past eight we'll be joined
by one of the government's vaccine
advisors
following the change in advice about
people under 30
taking the astrozenica vaccine
twenty past eight will talk to the
surfers aiming to clean up a
million miles of british coastline to
combat
plastic waste
now the prime minister and the irish
foreign minister have condemned another
night of violence
in belfast police were attacked petrol
bombs thrown
and a bus set on fire during
disturbances around the loyalist shank
hill and springfield road areas
our senior island correspondent david
blevins report
they were running a mock on shankle road
in belfast
these teenagers petrol bombing a bus
with the driver still on board
northern ireland's first minister
condemned it as attempted murder
the prime minister said he was deeply
concerned by the violence
but this community has given up on
politics and policing
sinister elements are exploiting the
youth and police are under attack
this is not the fault of the front line
police officer
this is a failure of politics and i
believe
there are questions to be asked at the
most senior level in policing
about their ability to lead in a
consistent manner
you know and the only thing that should
govern policing is the rule of law
this tension's been simmering for months
over the brexit protocol
but a decision not to prosecute anyone
for breaches of covert regulations at an
ira funeral
was the tipping point in the loyalist
heartlands they're losing
faith in the peace process stacy graham
a community activist
says nothing ever seems to change this
community has been left behind
we still have high levels of multiple
deprivation we're still living in
poverty
educational under achievement is a
massive issue we have really poor
elemental health
and people just feel really left behind
and disconnected from
mainstream politics dale pankhurst says
he understands the anger
but wants young people to make the
choice he did politics
not violence people are hugely
frustrated they're sick so and tired of
this
but there is a way to change it that's
what that's the message that i must say
if you engage if you empower yourself if
you educate yourself
you then in turn empower and engage your
community and that can make the the real
difference
brexit always posed a risk here
republican violence in the event of a
land border
or loyalist violence in the event of a
sea border
its rock the fragile pace the fact that
society here is still divided by walls
like this one
points to a failure of politics for all
the hope of the good friday agreement
there has been precious little
reconciliation and for as long as one
side is deemed to be winning
and the other losing there will always
be potential
for civil unrest it's against this
backdrop
scenes reminiscent of the past that
storm and leaders are under pressure
to demonstrate a political alternative
to street violence
david blevins sky news in belfast
also making the news this morning police
have confirmed the body found
in a lake in essex is that of the
missing student
richard kuragai officers investigating
the death of the 19 year old
say they don't think that anybody else
was involved
the trial of former police officer derek
chauvin has heard the use of force
against george floyd
should have stopped once he'd been
arrested and handcuffed a police expert
supported prosecution claims that mr
chauvin's knee was on mr floyd's neck
for about
nine and a half minutes myanmar's
ambassador to the uk was left on the
street last night after he was locked
out of his embassy in central london
he said there'd been a kind of coup and
his building had been occupied
he's previously spoken out against the
military takeover
the uk has halted all funding to the
charity oxfam following allegations of
sexual misconduct by aid workers in the
democratic republic of congo
two oxfam workers have been suspended
and officials say
no new grants will be awarded until an
investigation
has been carried out app users should
have greater control over how their data
is used according to apple
the comments come as the company pushes
ahead with plans to launch its
app track transparency tool meaning
developers will have to ask users
for permission to track them
this is sky news breakfast let's see
what the weather's going to do for you
today
uh higher or lower nas it's like a game
of play cards right
i know i realize i said that earlier
didn't i uh where will the temperatures
become higher or lower
well today it's feeling less cold than
recent days
but it's for one day or one day and a
half only because the rest of the week
does
look to turn colder with wintry hazards
again
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so less cold conditions
across much of the uk and ireland for
today with a westerly airflow that's
also bringing cloudier skies
and some spells of rain likely across
parts of the north for today
and some scattered showers elsewhere in
fact it's vastly a cloudy start for this
morning
less cold than recent warnings though
and not as
frosty either we are seeing spells of
rain though across parts of scotland
northern england and northern ireland
heaviest over north west scotland with
some
hill snow there currently and a few
showers scattered out towards western
areas through today that rain across the
northwest will slowly spread its way
south we're still with locally heavy
downpours
to southern scotland northern ireland
later island wales and england staying
mostly cloudy with a bit of brightness
and some scattered showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast we're going to talk to the
chief inspector of offset as they
started investigation into allegations
of sexual
harassment in schools in england
first of all make sure that you have the
kettle boiled and there was a big debate
on um if you should add the tea bag
first
or milk what i say is you should get
take your tea cup
put the tea bag in first then add the
water let it brew for the recommended
time
on the brand and then take the tea bag
out and then add your milk it's really
important you do it that way because you
won't be able to see
the strength of the tea otherwise if you
add the milk first
and if you have the milk first you could
be left with a very muggy cup of tea
if you add too much really where this
whole idea of
putting the milk in first comes from
when porcelain first came to the uk
not everyone could afford it so a
cheaper earthenware version was made
and that cheaper version couldn't
withstand the
heat of the hot tea so the teacup would
crack
so what people would do first is they
would add the milk that would really act
as a seal in the teacup
and that would help so when the tea was
added um
it wouldn't crack so that's really where
it comes from in order for you to see
the quality of the tea and strength of
the tea
you can't do that if the milk's in first
well there are
a range of elf teas available and if
you're going for afternoon tea
maybe you want to have something a bit
more um
luxurious like a darjeeling and if you
did you definitely wouldn't
add milk if it's more every day there
are a whole host of different
uh tea bags available personally i drink
blue sleep tea
a lot at home and it's very easy to make
it's not messy
at all as some people think and so a
real mixture
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los
angeles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well health secretary has said the
decision to give under 30s a choice
not to have the astrozenica vaccine
shows the medical safety system is
working well
talking to us in the last half hour matt
hancock said regulators were being
transparent
and offering as much information as
possible
the rollout of the vaccine is working
we've seen that the safety system is
working because
the regulators can spot even this
extremely rare event
four in a million and take necessary
action to ensure that the rollout is as
safe as it possibly can be
and we're seeing that the vaccine is
working
it's breaking the link between cases and
deaths
the number of people dying from kovid
halved again just in the last
nine days since i last spoke to you
and is down 98 from the peak
so we we can have confidence people can
take confidence
that we have a system that we are
extremely careful
on the safety front but that the rollout
is progressing at pace so when
when you get the call get the jab
now the school's regulator ofsted is
today stepping up its investigations
into allegations of sexual harassment at
schools in england
inspectors will carry out visits to
schools where students report incidents
of sexual violence well let's talk to
the chief inspector of ofsted amanda
spillman good to see you
this morning look how prepared are
inspectors
for this sort of work is i mean it's a
totally different realm from what
they're
normally used to on the contrary
inspectors are extremely well prepared
for this
excuse me they're all experienced school
leaders and they've had specific
training in this area and of course they
inspect safeguarding in every single
school we visit
so they cut this conversation about what
schools are doing to protect children
what they understand
about the risks that they're exposed to
it's a really important part of the work
we do and has been for very many years
well that begs the question i mean if
part of what they're doing is about
safeguarding children and now
thousands of people are coming forward
to make complaints it would indicate
that they've
not been doing their job properly
they've not been seeing this problem
one of the most obvious things it's
throwing up is that there are things
that are not coming to school's
attention
um that perhaps should be coming to
their attention or could be coming to
their attention because we can only
inspect and discuss
with schools on inspection things that
schools themselves or children tell us
about
i think what everyone's invited is
showing quite how much
some a lot of which happens in that sort
of blurred space with
people children with with friends from
school or not friends from school but
outside school it's the crossover very
often between
things happening outside school bleeding
into children's lives in school
how we address that how we help help
make sure that young people especially
girls
feel that they can report that they can
talk about these bad things that are
happening to them
so that so that the adults in and out of
school can do
everything they can to help educate to
help protect and to help deal with
specific incidents
so is this a case of saying you you're
not necessarily thinking this is a
failure on the school's part that
they've allowed this culture to exist
but
they've just not been aware of it
i don't want to prejudge what we find
we're doing a thematic review that's
going to look at a sample of schools
some of which will be schools which are
named on the everyone's invited website
but the point is not to
investigate individual cases or schools
it's to put together this wider picture
and say what is it and what what are the
aspects of the problem
um that are of greatest concern to young
people and what are the things that
existing systems
do well what are the things where there
is there is more that that potentially
could be done to help people
focus um on thinking about the problems
in the right way and
to moving towards things that can help
and help fast does there also need to be
a bigger focus on preemptive action i
mean clearly this is
about looking at the problems that exist
but in terms of preemptive action
such as you're having more more focus on
on empathy and understanding in schools
and respect as well i guess
absolutely and most schools take already
take this very seriously
they have programs of education um
relationships and sex education for
example as well as a wider
personal social health education this is
something where a great deal of effort
goes in it's about making sure that it's
going into the right things and that
it's actually having the intended effect
um that what young people go out and do
um
at weekends we hope reflects the input
they have at school and
and at home and we need to understand
where those disconnects are to really do
the very best we can
i i do just wonder if if any young
people who've
who've been onto this website and have
have lodged
what's happened to them are watching now
they're gonna say are you saying
all this work is being done schools are
very empathetic towards it you know
there's
sex education and all the rest of it but
they're still gonna say well this has
still happened
this has still happened to me so
whatever has been in place has not been
enough
that's precisely why we're doing this
thematic review nobody wants to read
stories like these and one of my i have
such a big concern about the fact that
so many of these young people have felt
unable to tell their school what's been
happening to them
understanding these disincentives to
reporting because
many of these schools think that they
have good roots
people that children can trust who they
can talk to and yet somehow
it's not it it's not always adding up
that's what's clear so
how do we make sure that the pieces add
up to something that gives
young people the confidence to report to
talk about these things
mansfield really good to talk to you
thank you
now just days before the lockdown eases
in england and more
venues reopen the nhs track and trace
app
is changing the government wants more
people to check in when they arrive
at a public place well let's talk to our
reporter
melania vasilinovich who joins us now so
what exactly is changing how will we
have to change our behavior molena
well there are three significant updates
to tracking which the government hopes
will keep a handle on cases once
hospitality and retail resumes
on monday now let's take a look at what
they are
number one when a group enters a
hospitality venue every individual
must check in using the app or providing
their contact details now previously
just one member of the group
was required to do that number two if
someone tests positive they'll be asked
to share what venues they've been to
we're told this will be done in a way
that protects users privacy and their
hope is
it will alert venues faster and help
contain local
outbreaks number three if a person
visits a venue on the same date as
several others
who test positive they may receive an
alert telling them to book a pcr test
whether they are showing symptoms
or not now previously people were
normally just asked to isolate if they
didn't have symptoms
also new qr code posters will be have
been developed which all venues in
england are legally required
to display now we do know from past
experience that
once people start mixing more inevitably
cases go up but the government hopes
that
this new and improved tracking system
will work together with
the testing with vaccinations to make
sure that things stay
under control as we enter this new
perhaps most critical stage
of reopening on monday when shops and
pubs and restaurants
start working again okay velena thank
you
the government in mozambique has called
for international support to deal with
an islamic state insurgency dozens of
people are thought to have died when
islamist militants attacked a hotel
complex in the town
of palmer two weeks ago the sky news
team was amongst the first journalists
to reach the amarula hotel where they
were shown what locals claim
were mass burial sites and the scenes of
a massacre
well attacks by insurgents have been on
the increase in mozambique's north
over recent months but in a major
escalation militants invaded palmer on
march
the 24th many foreign workers were
trapped for three days at the amaroola
lodge hotel
a convoy of vehicles attempted to escape
but was ambushed
dozens of people including a brit were
killed
sky news was the first international
broadcaster to reach the center of
palmer
after the attack and our special
correspondent alex crawford
said this report a convoy of contractors
and journalists made its way into palmer
the mozambican government wants the
world to see this
we were taken under military escort with
armed soldiers accompanying us the
president
insists the militants have all been
cleared from here but his forces were
caught off guard
and almost certainly they'll need to be
international cooperation
if mozambique is to defeat this
terrorism
the residents are returning slowly
they're amongst the poorest in the
country
and there are worries that some may have
been seduced to join the armed group
through poverty and desperation
there are suspicions the terrorists
managed to infiltrate the town
and may have had inside help palmer is
now swarming with soldiers
it's a militarized zone but the
president's accepted he can't win by
military means alone
and has promised many more jobs for the
young
one contractor with us was aghast at
seeing the damage done to his business
you see what's happened this outside you
see you think the truck is okay i opened
and everything's bent inside
it's going to be tough to restore
confidence here
i finish with mozambique i'll try to
sell my company
i cannot stay i've got family i need to
take care of
them
there's an ongoing investigation into
not only how the militants managed to
overrun the town
but how they went on to lay siege to
this hotel
which was packed with nearly 200 people
amongst them
expats foreign workers and villagers
who'd taken refuge here
the amarula lodge has been ransacked now
by looters
who seem to have gone into every room
turning it upside down
and stripping it of valuables foreign
who had workmates trapped here
it's a difficult journey just imagine
when i was speaking with my guy
how they was feeling to stay and
to know around them it's all these guys
want to kill them with the terrorists
closing in on them
some came up with a plan to break out
it was only a few miles towards the
beach and possible safety and the option
was
because they couldn't leave by
helicopter that they'd try and hatch a
plan to leave by
vehicle 17 a convoy of 17 or so
vehicles that we're going to move out
and
rush to safety but almost as soon as
they
exited the gates of the amarilla they
were ambushed with a number of the
militants hiding in the bush outside
and shooting specifically at the drivers
only seven of the vehicles made it
amongst the dead was britain fillmore
his body was recovered from one of the
abandoned vehicles
and when the villagers returned they
made a horrifying discovery
under a tree opposite the amarula lodge
they say a massacre
took place they led us to where they
insist they found a dozen bodies
now buried but all foreigners
all of the bodies were laid out under
the tree
there's still little known about the
armed group who carried out these
atrocities and caused such
destruction here and where in this
desperately poor area they are getting
their funding from
no no we don't know the reason why
they're fighting
or who the enemy is right now they need
to ensure it's secure enough to rebuild
and first priority is restoring the
phone network
okay it can make a huge difference for
people to find their loved ones
that are missing and have been able to
communicate yes we think it will
contribute
a lot to just help stabilize the current
situation
and ease the pain over the next few days
southern african leaders will gather in
mozambique to hammer out plans to combat
this terror threat
amid growing alarm at the insurgency
spreading
alex crawford sky news in palmer
mozambique
well still to come on sky news breakfast
how the government is giving
an extra level of support to the
hundreds of thousands of hong kong
citizens
expected to move to the uk
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up out and are
being used as missiles of hell
at these police
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news we have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check
our identity
[Music]
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why not meeting you fishing does have
the potential
to stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
for wherever you are welcome to the
safety regional day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we make
small changes to our lives
we can reduce air pollution by loads but
how much
exactly loads
it'll be less cold than recently today
but generally cloudy with rain spreading
southwards over scotland through the day
and to northern ireland later it'll then
become brighter from the north but
colder with wintry showers and elsewhere
we'll see showers spreading eastwards
across ireland wales and england in
between some bright or sunny spells
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 or 10 being
very high
most places will remain at a low level
of 1 to 3 again
however some isolated pockets of
moderate air pollution
may persist over the northern isles and
along the coast of northern scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now the trial of derrick chauvin the
former police officer accused of
murdering george floyd has heard that
the use of force
should have stopped at the moment mr
floyd was face down on the ground
and had stopped resisting mr chauvin
denies the murder and manslaughter of mr
floyd in may last year
our u.s correspondent greg milam reports
the amount of force george floyd was
subjected to in the moments before his
death
is the key question in this trial jody
steiger has invested more than two
thousand
cases of use of force by police he isn't
the first to tell the jury that what
derek chauvin did to george floyd was
excessive
as the time went on clearly in the video
you could
see that mr floyd's uh
medic his his health was deteriorating
his breath was getting lower his tone of
voice was getting lower his movements
were starting to cease
so at that point uh as a
officer on scene you have a
responsibility to
realize that okay something is not right
something has changed drastically from
what was occurring earlier so therefore
you have responsibility to
take some type of action he was asked
whether as the defense has claimed the
bystanders who were there that day
represented a hostile crowd that
distracted officer chauvin
i did not perceive them as being a
threat
and why is that because they were
merely filming and they were most of it
was their concern for mr floyd
the prosecution also played part of an
exchange between the officer and mr
floyd
recorded on a police body camera which
they say showed he wasn't distracted
when george floyd says i can't breathe
officer chauvin replies that it takes a
heck of a lot of oxygen to talk
the jury was shown this photo of officer
chauvin taken by investigators
a belt full of equipment would have
added to the weight on george floyd they
said
the court saw this cctv of mr floyd
arriving that day
he was under the influence of unknown
substances the court heard
the defense say he died of an overdose
that day
the prosecution that the cause was far
more visible
greg milam sky news minneapolis
now the british government is to give
extra support to the hundreds of
thousands of hong kong citizens expected
to move to the uk
they've applied to move here after china
introduced controversial new security
laws in the city
well let's talk to simon chang the first
hong kong holder of a british national
overseas passport to receive political
asylum but good to see you and of course
you were all in the
the headlines over here when you were
detained trying to
to cross back into hong kong from
mainland china
can you just remind us what happened to
you
well that's uh it actually uh my
experience was
into august 2019 i
uh i i was on the business trip for the
british consulate
generals in hong kong in shenzhen but
when i've been back
uh in hong kong physically in west kawa
which is in central
hong kong i've been stopped and
delivered back to shenzhen i've been
interrogated
for political reason i've been suspected
as
like a person to instigate the protest
back to hong kong
so i've been interrogated by the
national security police that time
but i have a very lucky uh because that
i've been released
look how many people do you think
are actually actively wanting to leave
hong kong now under the
the current regimes well based on the
extreme numbers of the home office it
could be
about three hundred thousand uh you know
citizens with their independence to come
to the uk
over five years but when we see the
rates
of the applications now um actually with
far exceeds that's the
estimated numbers of the home office
which is good thing because it's quite
attractive
uh to uh hong kong people who wanted to
flee
from the tyranny so i believe that
there's quite many hong kongers they are
losing hope
to achieve moxie and lance they
definitely wanted to fight
haytham now there's 43 million pounds
going into this scheme
to to try to make things easier i mean
what is the process like
now in having getting that produce
overseas passport
and then actually being able to come to
the uk
well so far at this moment still that
they need to apply that online
audacity through the website for the [ __ ]
visa and that's they need not to have
valid to be a new passport they come
here as provided they have a
pno status and then they can they can
apply
the bno visa so far we're very
appreciative
and grateful for the uk government and
because that's the provide very
comprehensive and powerful support
package
for hong kongers to uh reset tours in
the uk
um although we haven't uh uh know about
more details how to apply for that fund
but
as uh founders of the hong kongers in
britain one of the uh civil society
organizations to provide the support
uh to hong kongers um i think definitely
in the future
uh will be in blue uh to understand that
how
we can proceed concretely but definitely
that would be a very great means
for most of the hong kongers especially
that's being all citizens
but i wanted to uh i want to remind uh
one thing is that still a lot of hong
kong people
uh especially not been chilled uh by the
bl visa
because either that their parents
haven't
uh
that's their parents and not you know
they have a different political
preference then
maybe not allows their children uh to
come to the uk
so i think this bunch of people uh
especially some of those that
already in the uk uh they have been
uncompliment
children's i think that's that's
desperately a neat help
i think that's also need to be included
and definitely will in the future
to keep communication with the uk
government on this so
so we we need to make the remit
wider to to allow people to to have
easier access from hong kong to the uk
i i think so that's like uh uh
what what's the audience what what the
feedbacks of the audience will receive
also
they think that they they they wanted to
try them
uh try backstage out to to to sell
sustains in the uk
and i think that's you know um this part
of their supportive
package for hong kongers could be a very
powerful launch pad for them
to contribute the uk economy but of
course for sure
the uk democracy simon i get the
impression you you quite like being in
london
looking at the hats yes exactly yeah i'm
living in
uh east london i think that is a quite
a precious opportunity for me after
previously i have one year
uh studying at llc so i'm i'm quite
familiar with london
but i'm very glad that i'm a bank uh
that's i can enjoy
the democracy and freedom which i cannot
uh to have it back to my home towns in
hong kong
so i'm very appreciative that the
british society and the governments
that provide this kind of opportunities
for hong kongers
i think also the uk live up the promise
and more applications that previously as
a british colony
that's the um the freedom should be
enshrined by
the sign of richard joy decoration
although that's a kind of rich head
so i think that's very very grateful i'm
afraid we're out of time but it's good
to talk to you simon thank you
thank you so much thanks
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's going to be less cold
today due to a westerly airflow but
that's also bringing through cloudier
skies for today
as well as spells and rain currently
across parts of scotland
uh north of england and northern ireland
we're seeing outbreaks of rain heaviest
over
northwest scotland where there is some
snow over the high ground there and
there's some showers scattered out
towards western areas
elsewhere though it's mainly dry but
it's cloudy and less cold than previous
mornings and going into this afternoon
we continue with the predominantly
cloudy skies there'll still be some
bright or sunny spells though across
parts of england wales and ireland
but some showers at times are possible
well scattered ones
meanwhile across northwest scotland rain
there with heavy downpours will spread
southwest to southern scotland and
northern ireland
later behind that it will become
brighter but much colder with wintry
showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways